as I record this the Unicode consortium
has just announced 215 new emoji and
there was much rejoicing
unfortunately they include things like
man in business suit levitating and
there's a reason for that and was a good
question which is why er emoji in there
in the first place I've told about you
McCulloch before it's meant with this
universal language well no universal
code that includes every other language
it's meant to contain every single
script every single character you could
possibly put down that has any meaning I
mean it's got linear a in it nail which
is an ancient language that no one
understands but the characters from it
are in Unicode and well sour emoji but
why they're not they're not something
that you'd deliberately draw they're not
doodle a ball in the middle of a
sentence in scrawled rifted languages
but they're in here and the reason goes
back to the 1990s and well it's an
example of a standard that the rest of
the world imposed on us English speakers
1999 and we go to Japan now Japan at
that point had well walled off private
mobile internets it kind of had web
access on them on the cell phone
something close to it but really it was
like AOL used to be if you remember that
they used to try and funnel everyone to
their browser and their platform and the
Japanese mobile phone companies made
that happen there was one called to Como
which had AI mode I'm probably
mispronouncing that but now I'm an
English speaker so that's what I do
um and the idea was well we've got
enough bandwidth to send text that's
about all we can't send pictures but
what we could do because we're not using
ASCII we're not using the standard
english-speaking code that says a is one
byte and B is another byte we're sending
Japanese characters we're essentially
sending pairs of bytes that say put this
picture in put this character in so why
don't we make some of those characters
pictures why don't we have a smiley face
why don't have a few other things and
one engineer she could taka carita watch
me looking at my notes to make sure I
get that name right uh-huh she could
target carita and came up with a list of
176 characters
they were counted 12 by 12 pixel grids
really really simple and they were
pretty much arbitrarily chosen by him
and whoever he asked they'd includes a
couple of company logos for crying out
loud they included the sponsors of I
mode and the idea was they would install
those on the films that they sent out to
users and so instead of having to send a
picture they would just send a character
code the same as for any other Japanese
character and if you're using an AI mode
phone you would send a smiley face and a
smiley face would come out the other end
which was great if you were both using
I'm old phones but then all the other
network providers came up with their own
list of emotion generally different not
it all but in most of the characters
they chose different ones that shows
different interpretation so if you sent
one character from an AI mode phone to
someone on another network then it
wouldn't come through as intended so
that's the first stage
Stage two along comes the Unicode
consortium and they say write all these
n coatings of all your letters were just
no put them into one central thing and
put them into Unicode everyone can agree
on it you can send your documents
internationally brilliant except all the
Japanese people consult when they said
great you're putting emoji in there as
well right and the Unicode consortium
had a very long and very pitched battle
about this and eventually decided that
yes emoji would be going in because
because one of their their goals is that
you should be able to translate two ways
you should be able to translate
documents into Unicode and out of it so
you need emoji in that or you're going
to lose data so in go the emoji and
that's stage two stage three for comes
along over a few years later now Apple
is launching the iPhone in Japan and one
of the first complaints to get back is
it doesn't have emoji we can't answer
just coming to his junk
so Apple in iOS 2 way way back when I
had emoji but you needed a Japanese SIM
card in them no one really noticed I
asked for iOS 5 come along they decide
well we might as well turn this on for
everyone everyone's using Unicode now so
it's just add a keyboard in there that
says emoji it wasn't meant to go
worldwide it was never ever meant to
become as big as it did and yet someone
noticed Oh
I can I can have MIMO why am I not
holding my phone for this so on when oh
I can't have an emoji keyboard there's a
there's a setting in there and then they
sent a smiley face I'm gonna pretend it
with a smiley face let's be honest it
was almost certainly the little pile of
poo they sent it to their friend and a
friend with an iPhone said that's
amazing this is brilliant how do I turn
that on and they did it and they sent it
to their friend they send to their
friend accidentally Apple had created
something wonderfully viral just by
turning on a hidden a setting so that
went massive and all of a sudden all the
other phone companies
Android Microsoft we going oh we've
we've got to add this as well because
people are texting these emojis -
Android phones and and we're not
understanding them so they additive um
web browsers now have to try and cope
with it our Firefox does very well
Firefox will look through the other
fonts on your system through emoji and
use them if it can Chrome fails somewhat
there's all kinds of hacks being put in
there everyone is trying to add emoji to
their systems again never intended to go
this far but here we are and then well
people don't understand where this came
from which is let's be honest pretty
much everyone are looking at the list of
pictures and they're going Apple because
they've assumed this is an apple thing
Apple why have you added bento box but
not say taco and what is a bento box is
it's a kind of lunch box they've said
Apple wife why have you added this kind
of kind of weird five-pointed blossom
with a circle in it and some writing
it's actually a good stamp that a
Japanese teacher would put on a school
child's work to say well done and the
saying Apple white why do I have this
symbol for love hotel and what is a love
hotel and I'm not answering that on this
on this video more importantly they've
said Apple why is there anyone black in
here now that's that's a whole cultural
context I'm really not qualified to
comment on but it is still a massive
oversight and Apple have the well fairly
reasonable defense that they're
following the standard because it was
never meant to be worldwide this was
settled on by one Japanese engineer and
a couple of his friends what nearly 20
years earlier that engineer never meant
this to go worldwide never
meant to be used outside Japan and yet
here we are
so Unicode seven has just come out and
this is the exciting one this is all
we've got new emojis we've got new
things to play with so when it finally
goes onto your phone you'll be able to
scroll through the list and you ever say
Oh brilliant they've they've added a
portable stereo boombox
like it was the 1990s and you'll be able
to say all they've they've added a five
and a quarter inch floppy disk like it's
the 1980s I'd say oh oh they've added
I'm not kidding here they've added a no
piracy symbol and the no piracy symbol I
am not joking here is a man with a beard
and an eye patch and a big ghostbusters
no symbol through it they've added
wingdings they have added the entirety
of wingdings you remember wingdings
right it's it's the it's the font that
was from Windows 3.1 that had all the
little symbols in it it has I'm not
gonna try and draw once if you are gonna
have to have superimposes imposed
somewhere they have added man in
business suit levitating that's the
formal title it was meant to look like
an exclamation mark and some kind of
record company's logo I don't know but
that's what's in Unicode those are two
hundred and fifty new emojis they are
from wingdings Y and I now know the
reason why the reason why actually does
make a little bit of sense the Unicode
consortium has looked at all the old
documents out there that use wingdings
they're looking at the emails that are
still going round that have a J in them
for no good reason because wingdings
mapped smiley face to J so if you put a
wingdings
smiley face in there and it gets mangle
it along the way it'll come out as a J
and and they're looking at this and the
same light we can convert these to
Yumiko that's going to be our priority
which makes an odd sort of sense but it
doesn't solve any of the cultural
problems I mean it just adds new ones
what you have here is the the equivalent
of those original emoji you have some
symbols that were decided on literally a
quarter of a century ago by some
engineers in Microsoft
we haven't solved any problems not yet
I mean Unicode rate hopefully will come
along because there is now a massive bun
fight going on about what symbols and
what emoji get added to kind of equalize
things in Unicode age and that's great
but it also worries me because what we
have here is essentially a language we
have some letters that are decided on by
a committee and that makes me that's
probably not quite the right emoji
there's going to be one in here that
something's happen somewhere in here
we'd like to thank audible.com for
sponsoring this computer viral video
they've got loads of books online so
head on over to audible.com slash
computerphile for the chance to chat one
out for free today I'd like to recommend
the most human human by Brian Christian
it all surrounds this Turing test the
idea of can a computer pretend to be
human and if that is the case then what
makes humans human really really
fascinating stuff so check that out
get over to audible.com slash
computerphile and thanks once again to
them for sponsoring this computerphile
video you need something that's gonna
work more or less for us tea or at least
not break things but still be understood
so what you do is you start by